WHAT EXACTLY ARE THEY AFRAID OF?
TULSI GABBARD IS A FORMER
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE AND
FORMER CONGRESSWOMAN OF HAWAII.
TULSI, IT IS STRIKING WHEN YOU
SEE PUTIN PROPAGANDA AND YOU
LINE IT UP AGAINST BIDEN
PROPAGANDA.
DO YOU THINK THAT WE'RE AT RISK
OF KIND OF MOVING IN THAT
DIRECTION RIGHT NOW?
>> WE ARE MOVING IN THAT
DIRECTION, JESSE.
YOUR QUESTION THERE, WHAT ARE
THEY SO AFRAID OF?
THEY ARE AFRAID OF THE TRUTH.
THEY ARE WAY FRAYED OF EVEN A
SINGLE VOICE COMING OUT AS
CHALLENGING THE POWER ELITE,
QUESTIONING THEM, DARING TO HOLD
A DISSENTING VIEW AND THEY ARE
AFRAID BECAUSE THEIR ARGUMENTS
ARE SO WEAK THAT THEY KNOW THEY
WILL NOT WITHSTAND THE LIGHT OF
THE TRUTH.
AND THIS IS WHY WE ARE SEEING
NOT ONLY FILL MOST OF THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, VERY
VIGOROUSLY DEFENDING AND MUSH
PUSHING THE BIDEN PROPAGANDA,
IT'S NOT ENOUGH, THEY ARE GOING
TO YOUTUBERS, THEY ARE GOING TO
TIKTOKERS, IT'S NOT ENOUGH THAT
THEY ALSO HAVE GOOGLE AND BIG
TECH BASICALLY WORKING FOR THEM
AND WITH THEM TO CONTROL WHAT
INFORMATION WE SEE AND WHAT
INFORMATION WE DON'T SEE.
NONE OF THIS IS ENOUGH.
BECAUSE THEY WON'T STOP.
AND IT'S NOT JUST THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
IT'S NOT JUST DEMOCRATS.
IT'S THE POWER ELITE.
IT'S THE NEOCONS AND NEO LIBS
WORKING TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERY SINGLE VOICE IN THIS
COUNTRY, ANYBODY WHO HAS GOT A
PLATFORM IS SPOWDING THEIR
NARRATIVE THAT THEY WANT PEOPLE
TO SEE AND HEAR.
THEIR PROPAGANDA.
AND THIS IS WHAT IS SO DANGEROUS
ABOUT THE PLACE THAT WE ARE IN
RIGHT NOW.
AS A COUNTRY.
WHERE THIS IDEA, THIS PRINCIPLE,
THIS FOUNDATION OF FREEDOM OF
SPEECH.
FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION IS
DIRECTLY UNDER THREAT AND UNDER
ATTACK.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
IT'S NOT SO DIFFERENT.
WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE IS NOT
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN RUSSIA.
WHERE YOU HAVE STATE TV AND
STATE CONTROLLED MESSAGING
ACROSS THE BOARD.
THIS IS WHERE WE ARE AT.
JESS IT WORKED SO WELL FOR THEM
DURING COVID.
IF YOU QUESTIONED ANYTHING, THEY
WANTED TO KNOCK YOU OFF SOCIAL
MEDIA, THEY WANTED TO GET YOU IN
TROUBLE BECAUSE YOU WERE SEEN AS
A DANGER TO OTHER PEOPLE.
NOW THEY ARE TRYING THE SAME
PLAYBOOK WITH THE WAR IN
UKRAINE.
IF ASK ANY QUESTIONS.
IF YOU SAY HEY MAYBE THE NO-FLY
ZONE IS NOT SUCH A GREAT IDEA OR
EXPRESS ANY SORT OF RESERVATION
ABOUT LAUNCHING INTO A LAND WAR
IN ASIA, THAT'S NOW SOMETHING WE
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO DEBATE.
DO YOU THINK THAT REALLY SHOWS
HOW WEAK THEIR ARGUMENTS ARE?
BECAUSE IF YOU ARE CONFIDENT IN
YOUR ARGUMENT, YOU KNOW, HEY,
LET'S HASH IT OUT.
WE ARE MEASURES, LET'S DEBATE
THIS?
WE GET THE BEST IDEA AND PUT IT
FORWARD.
ISN'T THAT HOW IT IS SUPPOSED TO
BE?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT OUR
FOUNDERS HAD IN MIND FOR THIS
COUNTRY IS THE STRENGTH OF THIS
PUBLIC DISCOURSE.
THE TOWN SQUARE.
PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO ARGUE AND
DEBATE AND ACTUALLY THEIR IDEAS
AND THEIR VIEWS AND MAYBE
FINDING HEY THERE IS STRENGTHS
HERE AND WEAKNESSES HERE LET'S
COME OUT WITH THE BEST POSSIBLE
SOLUTION THAT SERVES THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND OUR COUNTRY THEY ARE AFRAID
AND AFRAID TO ARGUE SUBSTANCE
ONE POSITION OR ANOTHER BECAUSE
OF THE WEAKNESS OF THEIR
POSITION.
INSTEAD OF SAYING LET'S HAVE A
DIALOGUE DEBATE AND DISCUSSION,
THEY INSTEAD IMMEDIATELY RESORT
TO NAME CALLING, SMEARS
CHARACTER ASSASSINATIONS
SILENCING AND CENSORSHIP.
THAT'S NOT WHO WE ARE AS AMERICA
AND THAT WILL UNDERMINE OUR
DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC IF IT'S
ALLOWED TO CONTINUE.
>> Jesse: I AGREE.
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE NOT
OBSTACLES.